analyzing the games we will we will see
all the games that were played one two
three and four okay some of them to be
honest none of them was really exciting
I mean let's let's put it the way the
way it is the fact that games three and
four were considered exciting it's just
all something just because one and two
well ridiculous
so not really serious but okay its World
Championship match and of course
everyone is so nervous especially I mean
there's there are like really really
huge stakes here for both for both
players the way that I wanna or I was
thinking to do our evening pretty much
every evening it's basically like a live
show like on ICC so I I don't want to
rely so heavily on computer analysis so
the reason I said I think that there are
huge stakes for this match
I think bigger than top 11 and and
pretty much bigger than any other match
that we've seen in a long really really
really actually a long time is well
first of all I think it's the first
match in since 1921
that's 92 years that the two players are
non Russian or Soviet ex-soviet Union
okay there was actually actually another
pile of was the previous one just an
aunt of Paolo's but both of them were
kind of already world champion so
without if you count it out and
obviously for one and well it's much
more interesting match than girlfriend
against girl funny he had just downside
I mean what was this up side against
girlfriend okay he could have won the
match 84 and everyone said wow it was a
girlfriend but it was as far as humanly
possible to imagine that and he was
almost close to one of the biggest maybe
the biggest embarrassment for a world
champion losing to player at that time
number 25 in the world so but here well
here he is absolutely huge upside me
you will win this match I mean maybe on
paper yeah you'll still think as power
the greater is to be like you know if
you will look at the performance and
everything but if you really look at
World Championship matches me no joke a
bit comic the spouse couldn't do it you
beat up a love beat Gelfand beat carson
assuming you will do it you want the
world championship in 2002 [ __ ] she
love and so on that's really me I mean
maybe just looking at those statistics
maybe it will be the greatest if you
just look at World Championships titles
and defending and so on so that's what
he has on his stake okay the other side
is very clear becoming one of the
youngest world champions ever I mean
being the top player in the world for
three years and actually just getting
the title so I think this might explain
at least the very low start so let's see
the beautiful games one into that
everyone's so excited and then we will
see a little bit after so we will be
seeing it without any analysis on ICC
and I will use tiny bit here for
preferably smart insight all just a mean
sight not smart okay
I was here actually well doing there
Wednesday interstates classes and I
think that I said more than once
actually many signs that well I think we
will see some Knight f3 g 3 B 3 from
Carlsen Justin exactly with that hand
move which basically means ok I'm just
the best player in the world I don't
need any openings I'll just move the
pieces and somehow I will outplay you
which basically works for him pretty
much so it wasn't any surprise to see
this on the first game okay
it would by the way it will be
interesting to see at some point if we
will start seeing like absolutely main
lines because so far third of the match
is gone
third huge nothing was really shown
there nothing I mean the players could
have been working half a year preparing
10
hours a day or could be at the swimming
pool watching a movies and the openings
and everything looks kind of the same
okay so they got a very very standard
position c4 could have been played
earlier I think that in these positions
before if Castle weekend turns supposed
to basically this is the green field of
the fianchetto Kings Indian okay there
have been many games like this actually
Karpov had several big games like
against Kasparov against Kamsky I think
that in this specific move over capture
here might be quite a serious
alternative first because when the
ponies on c6 the diagonal is already
blocked it gives black a lot of
flexibility for some things for example
if 95 94 is supposed to be already quite
strong because there's pressure on d4
and if take take white Bishop cannot get
to b7 so okay 93 is a possibility we can
still consider that but Carlton very to
believer to doing nothing and moving the
pieces play this way actually we have
seen a game here if I'm not mistaken it
was the rapid from Norway 2010 that
cousin bit a nun in a very similar
structure I mean for people that were
here basically they exchanged those
pieces and he played ecigs
and cousin won in a long game and
therefore this is a very very logical
very logical reply 94 min pretty much
automatic reply I would even say the
main idea is just to be able to put the
bishops to be opposing one another and
once you neutralize this Bishop it's
supposed to be quite alright for black I
mean there was some games like this okay
we can mention huisman against nan in
Amsterdam and okay as I ever against
goal at all of
okay obviously whose man is Galvan
second and none one of the strongest
players in the 80s and the other to a
say even goals are just very decent
actually I think I saved I'd inning in a
car accident if I'm not mistaken but
quite young one of the members of the
Armenian team that won the Olympiad and
God is actually a nice oily player that
I know quite well
a local Grandmaster all right so 94 was
played by enough Grandmaster in is
absolutely the logical reply button on
to can plate Knight b6 on the surface it
looks like well quite bizarre or wrong
way of playing is just giving the center
but the problem usually with those
hanging pawns is just how to defend them
so let's since I spoke for almost 10
minutes non-stop and surprisingly nobody
said a word so let's see a some of your
thoughts so how to defend the policy for
what are our possibilities
but then the problem moving the night in
many versions default thinking I think I
think this is a problem and well the
bishop is not defended if the bishop is
defended well you might have some fun
thinking about some 95 but the bishop is
just not defended at all so Queen b3
yeah this is actually a very serious
move black will play the most
straightforward which is Bishop e6 once
again attacking the pawn if white will
manage to consolidate let's say white
get few more moves walk the you on walks
you on okay white is battery does have
the center but Bishop e6 and not yeah
before yeah that this was what was
played in the game c5 right and he okay
I mean always something like this has to
be considered but I mean most likely
even bishop take looks somewhat twist I
mean Bishop think the problem is
something like this just looking at it
quickly actually this is this is maybe
big problems for black he needs a pawn
up but there are some really serious to
add I mean actually if always more than
a serious threat it's just probably
really really not pretty a five-night
9594 but black and played this way of
course you would like to get a bishop
here and if Knight g5 the big idea for
white I mean for example let us go into
a big series of captures to capture
capture here but white white will be
very happy in this position even even if
he will be somehow a pawn down I think
that black is in black is worst here
actually maybe I could first stake here
yeah because if take the content so it's
not even another pawn I mean this is
absolutely risk-free for white is a pawn
down but the b7 point is weak the King
is weak the work on f7 looks ridiculous
and I mean white white is just better
here that's impossible to play this
night against this bishop but I think
that black has this important resource
Knight to f4 and after taketake
impossible to take on c5 because on b7
because of 95
so just tactically Queen b3 is not
really working that great for white so
that yc5 was played and actually this
was not played by too many strong
players but it was played in some
correspondence game and you know those
correspondence games are really really
serious when I was really young I
remember hearing that you know and it
that was actually before Houdini before
all those things now maybe they're even
more serious like some people just
sitting one week playing a move you know
if it's a 2,400 sitting one week playing
a move you can probably play like 2700
so correspondence games out some of them
are amazing but better than Carlsen
Anand and some some of them quality is
just incredible so this was one game
we'll see that in a second
okay retreating the bishop is one
possibility
couldn't be three it mentioned as as
another one and then once again Bishop
goes to e6 and if Queen back this was
some idea for a petition obviously very
creative but b6 is also possible I mean
like black is like pretty much black is
for choice weather is better or not like
what what does he want to play in in
this position
all right so Bishop c1 so this was all
played already and here 95 people really
really liked like this move but another
move that was already played is 94 again
the same idea I mean I find this move is
reasonable as 95 if Queen b3 first of
all b5 is always a possibility but even
something like this I mean in the game
black very quickly got the initiative
here like just take take this is really
like once again really important to
understand whenever there is a bishop on
g2 if we can put a bishop on same
diagonal you just pretty much neutralize
this Bishop take everything that you
want to do so just to be certain like
it's better here actually white won the
game but no not not very very strong
players not probably masters level but
okay no none played 95 and here Carlton
played Queen b3 which basically already
you know is satisfied with at dois 95
back and thought but what really what
really can he play in this position I
mean the night the night is under attack
okay there was something there were some
ideas suggesting take on a queenie one
was another possibility
but if Queenie one think night before I
mean this is this just some dangerous
stuff this is this is one idea also
Bishop g4 is another idea
and then at some point we're going to
see e5 coming a big normal break on this
diagonal anyway
Queen b3 was played and it was here it
was an ins to decide if he wants it
wrong or not
there were some ideas that he can maybe
play b5 I mean I remember actually I
came in on the night Ben was already
kind of with all the analysis and all
seen the analysis any thought that well
b5 was possibility yeah
they show some lines that involve cap
that involve capture they're just see
those and then Knight to a5 I mean
probably you don't want to get this
position something like this actually
might play for white I mean now we open
the diagonal there's some weakness I
mean white can play here but Knight a5
and then the pawn captures on b6 looks
perfectly ok this is the analysis they
give it also equal ok I don't think
possible to blame a non-date all for
making this draw so basically nothing
happened they I mean like I said I think
six months of preparation or being in
the beach and you know hanging around
this game was like that oh it whether
Carson was you know lacking energy and
you know his play was less than its
normal level I don't think so I mean I
think for okay objective
I think he takes before was something
that he wasn't really expecting again
for me it wasn't it wasn't a surprise
the opening on the the contrary I mean
you know Ben is here and he will put our
videos from last week on youtubes and I
mean the amount of times that I said
Knight f3 g3 basically just okay you
know I'm just moving the pieces
I mean it's know that Carlton is I have
no like insanely talented I mean
insanely in any levels I mean in any
level but maybe because of that he
allows himself to be lazy I mean people
know that is kind of I don't know let's
put it this way right now
no no harm was done I mean if he will
win this title then we will say wow it's
maybe the greatest talent ever in just
history can be watching movies non-stop
and still become world champion if he
will lose or basically won't win then
you'll say you see doesn't matter how
talented you are you have to work now
the first game same Carlson like if you
remember when Houston came with a
novelty on move 25 in any big line in
the last two three years you should tell
me I don't is like I don't it's moving
the pieces and it's working against
everyone so it's it's it's also by the
way was pretty much working against an
and today he's just he's not playing
actually really best chess but today was
probably winning not we will get to that
okay so actually that's interesting that
a nun played that a nun play d4 I mean
somehow I thought that he might want to
go more with Defoe I mean he used to
play Evo was his main play and then he
had to basically change it because of
cause of kramnik interested in the match
in 2008 wasn't really clear what to play
against the petrov actually at that time
was
really really difficult to get anything
against there the patch off there are
some ideas that came up since then but
okay today you have maybe a better more
modern patch off which is the Berlin
that we have seen today but I was
thinking that Defoe might might be
played more but okay he already played
two times fo so yeah okay c6
yes um what is surprised by Carson I
remember I spoke today with someone I
thought okay maybe we'll go back to to
e5 but okay I mean pretty much every
opening is playable and possible at that
level I mean maybe we'll play maybe
Sicilian is actually the one that you
don't want to play against Anand of may
be the one that will favor and under
most in the sense of chances and all
those but the kaabah Khan is very solid
Carson had few games I mean actually not
many maybe they were even Rapids
remember one against a job of not that
was maybe in one of the vacant days but
definitely not major one to expect let
me actually your game number two
oh wait okay this this is the line did I
mean Karpov used to play well couple
used to play Bishop f5 and also many
games with 97 and 98 6 but Bishop f5 I
believe today became became the more
popular move cage 486 Knight f3
yeah this is this move not as I would
say not the main move in the position
supposed to be you're not supposed to at
least principle in theory is supposed to
allow 95 or it's supposed to somewhat
favor
it's not much favor whiter for example
96 is another move that actually is
being played like for example recent
game in this line is Adams be champion
in Dortmund to end their ha 24 months
ago I think the game went something like
that actually it was quite I mean this
is actually mainline they play here here
check something like quite interesting
like that not okay it was maybe a bit
better for white Adams had one of his
best tournament in life were winning it
seven out of nine before Kramnik okay so
he's 6 ok 95 is dug by the way step back
97 is of course d main move I mean just
not allowing this 95 and okay then we
see we will see this position and either
it's going to come with Knight f6 Queen
c7 in long castle or Knight f6 Bishop e7
and short Castle which is they actually
a none place this line a lot with black
I mean there are many games of or quite
a few games of an and with the black
pieces but this is interesting and in a
null head a game exactly this way this
year against Dingley and I believe it
was in a lock on Memorial we will see
when they
deviated I believe it was on very very
on the 14th move okay fo this is the
idea that white wants to achieve by
playing quickly 95 we can get F for and
why he could play 95 because black was a
bit slow it 97 hey check and moving back
somebody to actually I assume that if
take the pawn white is just gonna well
actually it can either take immediately
I mean you cannot take here because G 7
is hanging and the Queen cannot take so
King take I believe this is way more
than enough for point yes yeah I think
the reason is that in some lines he
wants the bishop not to be on d2 so the
Queen can go to a5 that is a very
typical idea in many of those positions
the Queen can go to a5 in many versions
yes so here instead of long castle
actually actually this is the line this
is the line okay there was several for
example instead of city just to tiny be
touch this point a bit more there was
Bishop d2 this was actually a game
played in the World Cup of two very
strong players Yaakov anko and Eleana
they played this version okay and they
actually made quite a quick draw here
Queen to eat to Quincy 794 okay really
just they took and took on e5 and was
quite a quick tour but okay c3 c3 will
seem to be like a huge surprise for
pretty much any of the players Bishop d2
yes so let's see Anand game from this
year
Queeny to was played by a nun oh yeah it
was in dalek a memorial before Queen c7
sorry let's see if I've taken now before
and actually he just Castle Dwight and
Castle short and white just a pawn up I
mean that's usually black supposed to
get like a a5 and b6 and get some you
know attacking the pawn chain and so on
but in the game
ding Levin didn't get to do anything
actually a nun was one of his best games
one of his best games this year that you
want Oh apparently they had some ideas
different ideas and if you ask me what
are the different ideas if I knew I
would be playing there or at least
assisting one of them so not going there
but long castle and actually very
interesting that this move was played
after the previous games that we have
mentioned after all of them we mentioned
when when study openings it actually
always very very interesting to to see
chronologically what was played and when
and who to trust like for example this
is another game of the player we already
mentioned before this is the now Kiev
against a Leonov tournament in Russia
was played two weeks after the World Cup
so in the end of play this against the
echo venko he played these two weeks
after probably is quite okay with this
line that was two months ago I think all
two and a half months ago it's quite
okay with this line in that game Eliana
played with black c5 Bishop e3 Castle
okay they got disposition king 94
Khan once again actually very very
similar structure to what we will we
might get in the game D takes e5 maybe
take like when they spawn and those
ideas a possibility actually D takes d5
walk d8 all right actually black should
not win this position but somehow he
went and won it
don't ask me how or why after h5
Whitey's model well white is okay maybe
slightly better maybe equal all righty
well Carson play just simple move castle
okay 94 I mean moving of the night is
really one purpose what is that purpose
yep yeah just exactly just just - I mean
in signing some lines in the calc on
like we see ideas of nine f1 some other
well just move the knight even so it
won't be exchanged and then and then g4
okay okay 998 c5 is one idea but Carson
took took and took I mean then this is
actually really interesting to to take
on e5 it wouldn't be my first instinct
what what is logically first instinct to
you for black for people that play
caracarno for people that now are
looking at the Carrick on
then this was played in the game this
was played in a game but it at least
mine it's not my first instinct to
capture the night exactly and then and
then many times with Quinn Quinn is only
two with the Queenie four and Quinn
exchanges it's so typical to so many
many many lines so which most should be
considered here this is interesting
it's actually interesting that the most
logical move is actually at least
according to the computer the the best
move
yeah Queen e2 is most logical just put
the Queen there and then yeah indeed
computer is suggesting okay if 25 is
very interesting I mean this this this
is very really dangerous I mean 25 is
the logical move where we're saying okay
play king b1 and okay like black is
maybe tiny words but no real weaknesses
and no big problems and so on
but this is really dangerous I mean this
immediately this this is not a bad one I
mean taking the pawn looks really Dane I
mean well maybe not dangerous anymore
maybe just over like this is really
dangerous Black has no attack he just
took a pawn but he has nothing overdoing
white just have everything open on there
on the King side yeah g4 is really I
think this side I mean probably black
should still be looking to exchange
Queens here with Queenie for but he's
already a bit behind here I mean why
didn't even waste any moving or white is
for certain better in here even with
exchanges of the Queen maybe can even
move somewhere this is computer
suggestion but just doesn't does I mean
okay without Queen black is very happy
right yes to fix the pawns everywhere
and but the problem is there are Queens
on the board and I don't know I really
like the square there but
maybe like g4 and then okay plays same
lines
it just looks somewhat dangerous for
black probably will play Queen d5 and
exchange the Queen's this way or another
but I can understand why Carson wasn't
so much in the mood for that
so he took we basically went to very
similar ideas so here it's interesting I
mean I said that we will look at this
game like okay like we're doing some
live commentary but still we already
seen the other two games I think that in
the first game there can be no
complaints at all for Anand I mean even
okay maybe Kasparov is one of those
players that if he thought is tiny
better in the first game with black he
might have play doesn't care white black
first game he might just play button and
I don't think what never had those
killer instincts but this game tiny bit
but especially the third game I think
the third game was horrible for for not
like really really horrible actually I
can tell you we will see the third game
I told everyone and I'm saying it he'll
live Oh somewhat like no I think the
match is over after the third game and
not in an unfaithful I mean if he
couldn't push in the position that he
had in the third game no today today yet
the miracle II he he didn't lose but he
just he's not going I mean I actually
kind of more and more thinking it's not
going to win a game in the match if you
somehow can avoid losing very nice for
him but I I don't think he's gonna win a
game so the question is when when it's
going to lose one and then I think it's
all over but this is also an interesting
position because okay after take I don't
think he's really playing for a win okay
the Queen Queen g4 was was a very
critical very very critical move
and actually here really interesting
what to play I mean there are two moves
that will that will very very seriously
consider then actually one of them to
players like correspondence game already
play that position so no job those are
real killers
so really the two moves that we can
consider are either King eight seven
just moving they're just moving the King
I don't know white is white kind of want
to take you I mean this is meaningless
this is meaningless
so King eight sir f5 is actually
probably the best movie it's interesting
that Carlson said he would have played
King h7 and not f5 which is more
accurate so first of all it's the after
King 87 king b1 okay well protecting the
pawn is not bad but now there are some
that's some ideas for for white mainly
involving this move it's a moment
for example if Luke 88 I really really
like this move I think it's a very
strong move one it paves the way for the
pawns to advance it controls more
squares around the King and for example
if I think the innocence d5 I think just
runs into big trouble after Bishop g5
yeah let's look at Queenie to the AFC
five after Bishop g5 already a big
advantage because the book is aiming at
the Queen and everything is quite
defendant I mean if pawn take I mean
okay that's not actually I think this
might be more precise immediately right
this is just checkmate pretty much so
they're the threat is to take but also
to take here okay black black up black
of course should not play c5 we can move
back but okay but then white seems to be
white seems to be playing in this
position c4 once again take take take
maybe move like Bishop before is
problematic at least this move I'm
saying at least because this is
interesting like for example such
position okay white is better but
actually when looking at it like just
very quickly I think this is much much
this is just winning right I wouldn't I
wouldn't waste any energy on looking and
Bishop before this just winning the game
the queen is no squirrels to stay here
and then when it moves back no something
like that somehow it looks very
dangerous for black and quite for free
but I think that this move that Carson
said he thought was wrong it's actually
actually a better move
the thing is that if they can take the
pawn on e6 looks weak well maybe it is
weak but black gets a lot of very quick
play with rook F 2 a2 is right now
hanging so just black just gets in a
very very quick play actually I think
that this position after take computer
is even tiny bit favoring tiny bit
favoring black or let's say equal but
that's not a way to go
so the correspondent I think it was a
correspondent came pretty certain went
Queen g6 now take okay because now he
has booked f7 it looks really dangerous
but the computer is not really he's not
getting very excited at least I mean g4
was played in the game they took and the
computers preferring f4 when saying it's
around equal okay
the game went take take a five walk to
g1 Bishop f8 and it was a draw actually
ok so this is this is first moment now I
mean does a nun have to play for a win
doesn't have to play for a win but
should we make effort to do I mean how
is he going to win the game again I mean
it's not going to be like same story
like with Topalov I mean basically he
warned the last two championships you
want basically because of rapid well it
beat Apollo because the polyp was so
terrified to play rapid games against an
and that he went kind of crazy in the
last game I mean that was really the
reason why topple of or main reason at
least he said but why he played with
white so carelessly like really
incredible he just did
was afraid of Rapids against girlfriend
he actually worn in Rapids the match was
six six and he won the match in rapid I
think against Carlson I mean rapid are
not necessarily any any you know any any
spot to escape for Anant I mean I always
remember in one of the melody Amber's
this was just unbelievable
Carlson finished with nine and a half
out of 11 in the rapid section II made
one door with grease shook and he lost
two even shook of course but he beat
everyone I mean like everyone like Anand
ramnik every player among young in the
rapid it's like plus 8 out of 11 games
and seriously they were like players
number 1 to 8 1 to 9 in the world and
several one or two tiny weaker so rapid
is not going to be any escape spot for a
now and so I mean if you don't want to
push in this position even though let's
say it's somewhat equal but maybe some
pushing all right well we'll save those
all those complaints for the next game
be five okay basically not much is
happening here I mean no attack let's
just push the pond to prevent white form
getting anything on that side at some
point is threatening to play some
minority attack but it doesn't really I
think want to to do that okay so here a
five okay one rookie see eight in here I
remember last year in the Panem I was I
was doing some commentary there and
mainly hanging around in tiny bit of
commentary but it was actually really
cool
Jasha was there from Lindenwood any
hanger a lot in the press room and Unni
sook was there and we looked at one
gaming when he shook found a way for a
repetition and I was joking you know
it's it's like seriously death of you're
thinking it said like you know you have
to be professional after all the
tournament it you're kind of forbidden
to make a draw you kind of start
thinking profession
about repetitions although of course is
there you know very very big fighter and
exactly the opposite that's why it was
funny but apparently those players are
finding a very creative way for
repetition Luke g3 threatening the pawn
and mission accomplished you know taking
here here here okay so that was just a
draw once again
oh no no big event I mean could could
have been more interesting I mean me
actually did seem to be the most
interesting point of the game which are
none chose to ignore so both games I
think together took two hours and
together tiny bit right the first one
was 1 hour and 10 minutes and the second
one maybe about an hour I was like that
like wow okay in the first game let's be
objective black was not really better
you cannot say hey like was better at
this point
but black had the choice in the first
game this game is non-event and in games
three and four black was okay in play in
game three black was better maybe more
than better in game four that was
probably winning so yeah I mean black
black black black probably wasn't was
maybe this position on the board is the
only position that blacks should be
thinking in the entire match of maybe
getting worse but okay from if Carson
want to get something with white well
either this Knight f3 c4 g3 whatever
gonna work so far at least Anandi's it's
holding reasonably with the black pieces
you